hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a video where I show you
something that makes me laugh
pretty much every day now I actually
don't know what I'm gonna call this
video because III just said we're gonna
show you this subreddit that I browse a
lot and it's called are people [ __ ]
dying and that sounds bad you may think
that I'm doing the 50/50 challenger to
try not to cringe or try not to puke
challenge but you'll see what I mean so
this first one here mom decides to kill
her son
they're always named like this and this
is what it is that's not the best
example - god it makes me laugh it's
it's it's stuff like this where the
title is something horrific and then the
end result is something not quite so bad
its clickbait yeah that's what this is
it's the clickbait supper that's what is
dog viciously bites finger off mixture
it's it's a strange mixture of like
people getting hurt I'm not too bad I
love this sub rate it's always an
adventure innocent man mauled by vicious
pack of felines
oh you happy Wappy oh you bad Wahby
don't lick the wolf on a taxman
viciously chewing his face off
[Music]
oh so cute oh that was so cute so you
could look I know this could probably be
put to a challenge but I haven't thought
of it yet I think it's just a fun
experience like just to go through and
watch this like it's so weird it's like
a combo trying not to cringe try not to
laugh try not to smile challenging you
know and I'm not gonna lump it into any
of the others categories this reddit is
this subreddit is just really good and
you guys can check it out so I'm gonna
stay a few more I'm gonna browse the
front page of it right now
woman rips off leg in horrible gym
accident I don't remember seeing this I
don't know it's blanked out innocent dog
[ __ ] mauled by albino Panther
[Music]
a lot of its animal just pink you ah
freak man mauled to death by pack of
starved oh this could go horribly wrong
this could go horribly wrong
ah why why is he there that seems like a
terrible idea but it's cute but also
terrifying
ah it's definitely good State Fair
brutally tears flamingos to pieces your
baby got a kill your baby's got
something home oh the bacon burger
oh that's so cute
baby bears are so cute except they're
[ __ ] terrifying pecking suicidal
delivery boy ends his own life in a
high-speed horrific motorbike accident
[Music]
like bad Oh or it's stuff like that
weird dude long slow fall over oh [ __ ] I
love I love the clickbait subreddit it's
my favorite vicious dog malls friends
pace oh it's so cute Oh your friend
planks cousin
oh no never recover cyborg dog goes on
rampage kills the cameraman that's what
this is like this subreddit is it's a
mixed bag that's the thing it's
everything it's everything all in one
it's everything you could possibly hope
for it's all better for the context of
which it's presented like these videos
they're shown on other places but just
in this specific like apprehensive
surprise of I don't know it's just it's
such a fun subreddit bird gets eaten by
crocodiles
Oh child eaten alive by pack of fools
[Laughter]
stop stop it you stop it stop that
you're too cute oh don't do that
oh oh that's too cute oh my god wait I
got it I gotta see this last one
psychopath choreographer summons tornado
to destroy the village oh man how do you
not get dizzy that's insanity insanity
Scott it keeps going holy [ __ ] okay
alright enough enough you've already
shown how much better you are than me
and everybody else here enough stop
Jesus okay there we go
Wow alright so anyway that is are people
[ __ ] dying if you want to go to the
subreddit I'll put a link in the
description below it is a lovely place
if you want to smile or laugh or cry or
go oh holy there's there's a few like
grisly ones in here but it's never that
bad so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think of
this now in the comments below and if
you have a favorite subreddit of your
own let me know that as well because
there's a ton of stuff out there there's
always good stuff it's just like the
literal thing is just the context it's
it's the same thing in a new wrapper and
that's what makes it great so thank you
again and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]